we'll be Audrey we know you wanted Lee
the queen of mean but you're just not
villain material even when you try to be
evil you just don't have the practice of
a true Disney villain we know you gave
it your best shot but we think you did
the right thing by going back to your
pretty in pink princess selves
leave the villainy and evil deeds to the
experts next time around but we sure do
hope that there won't be a next time
Audrey took over as Mel's and nemesis in
descendants three but was she as mean as
everyone thought we have some strong
evidence to suggest that Audrey wasn't
really a villain at all in d3 watch
until the end to find out why Audrey is
actually innocent and perhaps to chad
charming Audrey really wanted to be with
Ben but Chad was hopelessly in love with
her ever since the first descendants
movie chad has followed her around like
a little puppy dog he never missed an
opportunity to try and rescue her he was
quick to defend Audrey and her
grandmother during family day at auradon
prep and in descendants - Chad jumped at
the chance to drive all the way to the
enchanted forest to help Audrey when her
car broke down but as it turns out Chad
was the one who needed rescuing from
Audrey in descendants three even though
Audrey was determined to be evil Chad
never left her side but Audrey had the
chance to be way more evil to Chad she
sent all of the subjects of auradon to
Dreamland
but when Chad was annoying her she just
locked him in the closet she definitely
has a soft spot for Chad which made her
less ruthless the museum during Audrey's
malicious solo the queen of mean Shira
leaves the Museum of cultural history of
a few of its key items but at first she
was only going to take the crown it
wasn't until Maleficent staff beckoned
to her that she turned evil and stole
the sceptre but why did she stop there
she could have stolen fairy godmothers
wand too and who knows what other
treasures were in that Museum sure
Audrey was hurt and angry when she
started her song but was she capable of
doing bad things without the lure of the
scepter it whispers her name to get her
to come closer maybe the staff put a
spell on Audrey making her more of a
villain than she was capable of being on
her own she said it herself in Hades
woke her from her slumber she asked if
it was all a bad dream she was under a
spell for sure but was it the
intoxicating spell of revenge and
madness or was it Maleficent scepter all
along none of her spells worked Audrey
had access to the most powerful spell
casting tool in auradon
she had Maleficent scepter yet every
spell Audrey cast with this powerful
staff was easily thwarted
she cast an age spell on mal turning her
into a slow tired old lady but that
spell quickly evaporated when mal
crossed over the barrier and onto the
isle that was too easy
when Audrey launched the armored Knight
attack on mal Ouma and the rest of the
gang
they fought them off with ease and when
Audrey tried to shut her out the cottage
with Malin Ouma inside they joined
forces to make the board's fall away her
beasts fell on Ben was swiftly reversed
with a little enchanted Lake water and
even the least powerful subjects of
auradon were able to outsmart and defeat
Audrey proving that she was not the
powerful villain she was pretending to
be Celia
Audrey looked menacing up on that
rooftop when she was holding Celia
hostage now did the right thing when she
transformed into a dragon to defeat
Audrey and save Celia Audrey told dragon
mal careful not to fire little --zk
buddy
but Audrey could have hurt Celia too and
she didn't Audrey didn't put Celia to
sleep with her sleep spell which should
have made her much easier to control she
didn't turn Celia to stone either she
just gave her a firm bear hug and when
Celia got free from her grip she was
easily able to run from the queen of
mean on that tiny rooftop now had
something that Audrey didn't have she
had friends on her side Audrey was
completely alone in her battle Audrey
never stood a chance against mal and her
crew let's face it Audrey just didn't
have the experience to take over a whole
kingdom by force all by herself her
biggest mistake of all Audrey had the
perfect opportunity to defeat mal and
take over auradon for good and she
totally missed the mark
Audrey turned all of Mouse friends to
stone except for mal why did she spare
mal and let her go on to sing that
empowering song if Maleficent were there
she would have slapped that sceptre
right out of Audrey's hands total
villain rookie mistake
Audrey you had mal at her most
vulnerable but you let her get away now
turned into a dragon and defeated Audrey
reversing Audrey spell and saving all
avoid on perhaps Audrey should have
brushed up on villain history 101 so she
could have learned from the master
still we have to say we prefer the good
Audrey over the evil one if only she
could keep that wicked outfit and stay
sweet that would have made for a perfect
fairytale ending Audrey gave evil her
best shot but it came up short do you
think Audrey should have been punished
for her actions or was mal and Ben's
choice to pardon her the right decisions
tell us in the comments if you love
descendants as much as we do click that
subscribe button and get this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things see you next time
[Music]